[Music]
sherry which of you guest was the
biggest disappointment once you met them
in person
oh
i don't know i can't mccain wait
sherry shepherd just threw some not so
subtle shade at meghan mccain you know
i'm a pretty pretty um yeah i'm a
republican i think that's probably the
first thing people think when they think
of my name on wednesday the 54 year
old's comedian who was a co-host on the
view from 2007 to 2014
stop by watch what happens live with
andy cohen and didn't hold back when she
was asked the most disappointing guest
during her time on the show
oh
i don't know i can't mccain wait
yeah mccain wait translates to megan
mccain people i mean i think that's why
people like the show is they know it's
not scripted and they know it's not
we're not being phony and i'm not trying
to placate to an audience and after the
taping sherry poked fun at the comment
tweeting about drinking on the show and
getting in trouble quote all i can say
is don't drink and then answer questions
but this isn't the first time the tv
personality has shared her two cents on
the conservative pundit who also
co-hosted the view years after sherry's
departure from 2017 to 2021. i try and
just remind myself that i'm representing
50 of the country i'm representing a
bunch of women even though i only have
one chair sherry how do you think megan
mccain is doing on the view
um i you know she just
[Music]
she just has to evolve she has to get
used to sitting there uh at that time
and i think she has to not take the
whole republican world on her shoulders
too much right take that whole thing
yeah it's like you are not the
republican voice i know and so it makes
you stress makes you tense and so i
think you know being able to just
lighten up a little
that was sherry in 2018 and shortly
after megan went on watch what happens
live and responded to the critique i was
super bummed out when i saw her saying
that she said that i need to lighten up
and you know the view as we were talking
about before i came on it's it's a tough
show that's really political heavy and
we're a new show now and it's not the
show that she once hosted and right now
and not to make this too heavy but in
trump's america we shouldn't be telling
women to lighten up it's a serious time
we can take things seriously and while
shari's opinion about megan may not have
changed much she had nothing but sweet
things to say about another daytime tv
heavyweight wendy williams the
comedian's been filling in for wendy
while the talk show hosts heals from
ongoing health issues she made her own
path like what wendy does nobody can
recreate none of the guest hosts that is
specific wendy created that to spill the
tea you know and she'd sit there and be
like you know what i'm talking about
right so i love that and i love her
fearlessness and that is something that
i want to emulate and keep going you
know so she did she opened up a lot of
doors and she's up there with the greats
earlier this week sherry got emotional
after making this big announcement the
sheri show will premiere this september
and after the big reveal she shared an
inspirational message when you're
feeling like
you have been forgotten
when you're feeling like people say no
it may not be no
god may be saying
it's not time
and when god says it's so
it will be so thank you
and how's this for a full circle moment
the ladies of the view gave their former
co-host a shout out to congratulate her
on the new gig we're your biggest um
cheerleaders and fans she's she's a
great talent sherry she's laughing
she'll be so good
such a good person yes you know she's a
doll yeah she's a like person
when you listen to her you're just like
what's next year because she's always
got funny stories when good things
happen to good people it's extraordinary
[Music]
you